en fuerza mortal de primer orden y
completamente innecesaria estas son las
palabras utilizadas en el último
testimonio del oficio de derecha van el
viernes un oficial de la división de
homicidios de alto nivel que intervino
sobre la escena de la muerte de georg
floyd condenó las acciones de chabán con
muy razonables
tirarlo al suelo boca abajo y ponerle la
rodilla en el cuello durante ese tiempo
es simplemente improcedente y no tal
es esta
debería haber cesado esa sujeción una
vez que fue esposado y tirado al suelo
por supuesto absolut
el testimonio es crucial para los
fiscales que están tratando de demostrar
que las acciones de chabán violaron el
protocolo policial sobre la fuerza
causando finalmente la muerte de floyd
la declaración del teniente se produce
un día después de que el ex supervisor
de chabán también dijera que cree que la
sujeción agresiva podría haber terminado
una vez que freud fue esposado el agente
está acusado de asesinato y homicidio
involuntario por clavar su rodilla en el
cuello del afroamericano de 46 años
durante más de 9 minutos se enfrenta a
hasta 40 años de prisión si es declarado
culpable de su cargo más grave la muerte
de floyd desencadenó protestas masivas
en todo el país y en todo el mundo y
provocó un amplio examen de conciencia
sobre el racismo y la brutalidad
policial en eeuu a principios de este
año la cámara de representantes de eeuu
probó en efecto un proyecto de ley de
reforma policial que prohíbe las llaves
de estrangulamiento